For this module you're going to
want to open the file.
Lesson1_Constants&Variables.
It's another playground file.
In Swift there are two different
ways to assign a name to a value.
Values can be assigned to constants,
or variables.
Constants are declared
using the keyword let and
variables are declared
using the keyword var.
Not surprisingly, once the value of a
constant is set, it can't be reassigned.
The value remains constant.
So one should use let, when assigning
a value that's not expected to change.
Here, the encouragement
string stays the same.
So it's declared as a constant.
The personalizedEncouragement
string changes.
So it's declared as a variable.
Here's another example.
Birth year doesn't change, but
time keeps progressing forward, so
current year does change, as does age,
if age is defined as current
year minus birth year.
But it's important to keep in mind
that context matters, as well.
The previous example assumes
that the variable, age,
is going to be calculated
multiple times.
If age was only intended to be
calculated once, then we'd go ahead and
declare age and
current year as constants.
When in doubt,
declare a constant over a variable.
Any time a value is altered
it should be explicit.
This protects our code from
inadvertently changing values that we
don't want changed.
Let's do one more example for
good measure.
Here, birthweight isn't going to change,
so we'll declare that as a constant.
But currentWeight is going to change,
so we declare that as a variable.